qui comme dans le film serait prêt à
quitter la france par amour franchement
vous ici autour de la table qui seraient
prêts à le faire frédéric moi ouais
ouais vraiment toi questions sur bien je
vous pas amour c'est à dire quitter la
france la france salue et étrangers
ouais c'est vrai ça va c'est pas vrai
évidemment par amour loca-pass
évidemment vaut aussi pour tout le monde
ici vous avez déjà fait un truc fou par
amour quelques trucs le plus fou que
vous ayez fait beau ici autour de la
table quoi vous et je suis parti vivre à
l'étranger j'ai fait un enfant à 18 ans
je suis j'ai tout laissé mes parents et
mon plus parler je partis et des saluts
alors ici c'est pas mireille dumas s'est
dit ça fait des années que je suis lâché
s'avéra la [ __ ] là avec dan moussa
horriblement génome et alors on est
passé à une autre qui comme son talent
dans le film est complètement accro aux
réseaux sociaux il passe tout son temps
qu'est ce que j'apprends à gérer qu'il a
dit a 30 ans et on va dire les
transports tout ton temps dans les
transports en grèce beaucoup de temps la
trace par c'est sûr vous êtes souvent
sur les réseaux sociaux droit donc la
frappe pas qu est ce qu a révélé qu'il
n'est pas très près evous ici
personne personne ou alors bourrel d'eyl
alors elle sans réelle c'est un truc de
fou et ouais je m'endors avec je me
réveille avec même avant de faire pipi
matin non c'est reste un drame drogue
alors est ce il paraît que il paraît
qu'on m'a dit vous faisiez mène des
tests c'est à dire faisait même vous
voulez pas regarder votre portable
pendant jour ce jeudi pendant 10 minutes
c'est vrai excusez moi ici c'est pas
sophie davant et tout le monde en fait
j'ai remarqué deux groupes ils sont
premiers de ligue 1
[Rires]
dans cette équipe c'est que chacun un
gros barda temps ça sort est scellé
c'est incroyable c'est moi qui comme
christian clavier dans le film a déjà eu
une lubie qui rendait fou tout son
entourage puisque christian dans le film
vous avez vous avez une lubie alors
question en fait votre personnage a pris
sa retraite a décidé d'écrire un livre
sur alfred tu nous lis une grande figure
politique très important vous ne
connaissez pas mais c'est à dire du bien
des ismes le pyrénéisme oui vous savez
ce que c'est senna mais barten actuel de
la montagne avez vu le film
oui mais voilà donc qui marient le
sensible aux sportifs est ce que vous
avez une phobie boon lui voilà où une
lubie voilà que la main avant la télé de
leurs mots mature de lambeth et a une
phobie que c'est une lubie quoi c'est
vrai ah oui ma femme il va falloir
arrêter que ça bah oui mais j'aimerais
bien qu'ils reviennent déjà est-ce qu'on
a eu des nouvelles
matthieu delormeau il reviendra
normalement vendredi sachez le il a eu
des petits soucis mathieu 1 voilà il a
eu un petit problème à l'oeil mais voilà
j'espère qu'il sera avec nous l'émission
ils ont beaucoup de boxe est bon et
alors il ya une clinique
[Rires]
le salua me matthieu delormeau l'endroit
ce mot mathieu qui comme dans le film
d'horreur avec pyjama avec un pyjama un
peu ridicule vous dormez comment vous
christian d'abord ma vie privée ne vous
regarde pas le savoir non mais c'est pas
la peine
mais deux enfin bon voilà c'est long
mais comment ma pile ou en quoi mes bons
amis new rose oui c'est vrai voirie en
jeans quand j'ai un vieux bout déchirer
ce temps avec ça c'est vous parce qu'un
air de terre un ver de terre
pourquoi le seigneur poil oui j'ai un
ver de terre toujours à côté de moi
alors là tu vois déjà l'étoffé dernière
de deux shorts de bain je sais pas
pourquoi
short de bain l'ancienne piscine à côté
je peux l'être soi qu'elles sont tous en
effet vous aurez compris et même en ce
moment avec un t-shirt michel sardou xxl
taille homme est ce que on me l'a offert
le porte au niveau de la dépression nom
et avec un tir je cours beaucoup remonté
la pente
moi j'ai lu d'autres émissions si on en
était parti beaucoup c'est vrai que
c'est incroyable
oui ou non mais comment vous en slip on
slip
d'accord on se lie potsdam où miles site
mais tout est bon au cas où d'un dans
deux ex aequo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui tous les pyjamas sont ridicules par
définition et vous dormez en peluche un
bon témoin soit pyjama ridicule ou soie
et votre mac mais roger roger votre main
à votre mec qui dans tout nu tout nu
c'est lui qui m'a appris à dormir tous
les noms bah oui c'est tout ça juste
après la libération après dormir tout
votre prénom
incroyable tu vas te lever sortir chaque
tour du pâté de maison carrée à dormir
tenez c'est la première fois que de dire
que je vais t'apprendre quelque chose on
va tout paris sait très bien delphine à
bretelles fines a l'air très charmant
bien sûr si tu veux dire par là par
rapport à quoi exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aime beaucoup à harry et c'est
vrai que je le suis sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que moi aussi comme kelly
pour le coup on a un point commun c'est
que on est beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'adore c'est au fait merci
est ce que c'est
c'est vrai que maintenant ils veulent la
prendre à dormir billets c'est vrai cc
et vous n'y êtes vert anis ou nantel
vers aniche comme un bonbon nietzsche et
parce que jamais cette couleur un peu
pâlotte comme ça un peu à mende
oui ça fait flipper lycéens bâton à la
main et là on était dos messieurs rien